those days
when I'm tired or worn out or just
basically sick of the grind
what do I do on those days I go anyways
I get it done even if I'm just going
through the motions
I go through the motions I don't really
want to work out I work out
I I really don't want to hammer on a
project I hammer on the project don't
really want to get up and get out of bed
I get up and get out of bed you need to
get things done
yes it's possible that you can choose
your future and direct the course of
your life as you run towards your dream
it's necessary that you have goals that
you write those goals down that you plan
that you think constantly of how you can
begin to improve what it is that you're
doing if it's your presentations if it's
your recruiting skills whatever that is
it's also necessary that you look for
ways to always find a way to pull it out
when everybody else thinks you would
defeated that you've got to take
personal responsibility to know that in
order to become successful you've got to
make it your personal business to do it
it's not easy
it's hard changing your life you can
live your dream it was hard ladies and
gentlemen it was very difficult to pick
myself up each day believing and I could
do it there were times that I doubted
myself I said God why why is this
happening to me I'm just trying to take
care of my children and my mother I'm
not trying to steal a rock from anybody
how did this have to happen to me it was
very hard
and here's what I want to say to you
for those of you that have experienced
some hardships
don't give up on your dream
no one could have convinced me by
Holding On by continuing to push forward
by continuing to run toward my dream
that one day I would have my own talk
show the way to become a millionaire
if you could think of how to become a
millionaire you do it by Friday
you don't have to go that far all you
have to do is think of your god-given
gift all of you can do something
somebody will pay you ten dollars to do
I don't care if it's cutting grass
doing their hair
painting the wall
babysitting taking care of the elderly
teaching tutoring everybody can do
something for ten dollars
this is how I got to this place of
success my jokes were 25 a night
I made that for a long time
whatever you do to make ten dollars this
gift that God has given you at Birth
because God never created a soul he
didn't give a gift to all of you have
one I don't care if it's fried chicken
some of you fried chicken better than
anybody else baked pie do have something
do whatever it is for ten dollars after
you make the ten dollars I want you to
do it 10 more times you'll now have a
hundred dollars if you make a hundred
dollars whatever you did to make the
hundred dollars that ten dollar idea I
want you to do it ten more times you're
gonna have a thousand dollars now it's
gonna get a little more difficult but
after you make a thousand dollars
whatever you did to make the thousand
dollars I want you to do it ten more
times you now have ten thousand dollars
now now we gotta Focus now whatever you
did to make ten thousand dollars that
started off with your ten dollar idea
what I want you to do is focus I want
you to do it ten more time you now have
a hundred thousand dollars now this is
where it gets very very difficult you're
gonna have to hire some people you're
gonna have to pay some people some money
but you take that hundred thousand
dollars and you reinvest it and what I
want you to do is whatever you did to
make the ten dollars that you did a
hundred times and turn into a hundred
thousand dollars all I want you to do is
take that same idea don't change nothing
do it ten more times I got news for you
you have just made a million dollars
all right
I'll never forget the day I was like yo
I'm ready like for real I'm ready to go
Global I'm ready to change people's
lives I will never forget the day I was
like whoa I'm ready to take my game to a
whole other level
I remember I remember now you gotta
remember I'm a man of faith and so I was
praying and I heard it it was crazy I
heard it I was like all right what books
do I need to read I'm ready what
conference do I need to go to I'm ready
just show me the book I'm ready show me
the conference take me to the guru I'm
ready just show me what I need to say
you know my resolution my goal My
outcome for this month this week this
year is to lose X number of pounds
that's okay but it's not very compelling
it has to be a compelling Vision it's
got to have something has the power to
pull you not something you have to push
yourself to do those are two different
kinds of motivation push requires
willpower and willpower never lasts
what will last is pull having something
so exciting so attractive so something
you desires so much that you have a hard
time going to sleep at night you get so
up early in the morning do a rocket and
take it to the next level that's what
you're looking to create that wasn't
easy to get but one of the reasons we do
seminars and events and we say you know
why do that why isn't why not just read
a book or something is because when you
get an environment where you're with
people that are being put in a peak
State like when you're going to a
sporting event if you watch a sporting
event at home it might have a certain
level of excitement but when you're in a
stadium with 50 000 people suddenly it
has a whole different level of intensity
when we feel that and the bottom line of
our follow through comes down to our
emotional intensity in a different state
of mind you're going to come up with a
much better and more exciting Vision
than if you're sitting on the couch
going okay what are my new resolutions
for this year and you're doing it the
morning after the new year is started
and you're a little inebriated and the
football game's on the background
probably not going to have the power of
focus there probably not gonna have to
power the energy to create something
that's going to pull fool you for this
year and you got to do that you don't
let the fear take you over if you've got
strong enough reasons those reasons can
be positive or those reasons can also be
negative they can be if I don't do this
it's going to cost me
and if I do do this this is what I'm
going to gain in my life
reasons come first answers come second
if you get a compelling vision and you
got strong enough reasons that will push
you through the tough times you're going
to do things other people don't do
instead of collapsing even if you get
off Target you won't go oh I blew it
you'll get right back on target make the
change make things happen and I know
you've done this in many areas of your
life just think about it again I'm I'm
not teaching you something really new
here today I just want to remind you of
what your soul knows you gotta change
you gotta improve and you've got to go
through a simple process fundamentally
to make that progress First Step Vision
that's compelling Second Step make sure
that they're strong enough reasons to
follow through third step you gotta
review it and feel it every day
I mean anything have you ever had this
happen in your life has there been
anything in your life that you've ever
wanted so badly you were so desirous of
it you had such a hunger for it that you
couldn't stop thinking about it could
have been a career move could have been
when you're a kid a car it could have
been a relationship it could have been
anything but you were obsessed you
wanted to make this happen you wanted to
track this to your life you want to you
just wanted something and you didn't
even know how to get it but it was so
compelling to you kept thinking about it
every day envisioning and imagining it
feeling it and then stuff happened and
suddenly you started to attract people
or situations to your life and it just
came together like you don't even have a
total plan it was just that it was so a
part of your focus with so much
intensity and emotion so often that it
sensitizes you to notice anything that
could get you there